a week after they were sacked over a
screen piano staff gathered to watch
their former boss speak for the first
time his former employees outraged
almost matched by mps asking the
questions are you in this mess because
you don't know what you're doing or are
you just a shameless criminal
can i start please with an apology
if peter hebelthwaite is sorry for
sacking 800 people without notice he was
unapologetic about how he did it
brazenly admitting piano broke the law
there's absolutely no doubt that we were
required to consult with the unions we
chose not to do that because we believe
she chose to break the law because we
chose not to consult and we will come
and we are and will compensate everybody
in full for that despite mp's fury the
chief executive said he'd replace staff
with agency workers to cut crew costs in
half and save the company we did
consider every single option available
to us and we concluded that every single
option available to us
would result in the closure of pno among
those he fired there was contempt
redundancy packages are going to be less
than what he takes home every month
let's put that into context someone who
takes home
more
in one month than these guys are going
to get for losing their jobs if he
thinks that by turning up here today and
shedding a few crocodile tears and
saying it's the best we could do we're
not having it peter hebelthwaite told
mp's transport secretary grant shaps was
first told about the company's troubles
last year a claim his department denies
time
do you think we'll be wrong
the chief executive paid 325 000 pounds
a year ignored reporters questions as he
left ministers are reviewing maritime
employment law they now have to decide
what to do with his admission of guilt
the government needs to move much more
quickly
in making it very clear to people like
mr hebelsweight piano ferries and dp
world that they cannot act in this way
with impunity mr helpless ways should be
struck off as a company director
piano had hoped to have its ships back
on the water running between dover and
calais by now but the new staff they've
hired on wages of little more than five
pounds an hour are still doing training
drills on that ship over there and the
unions say their crewing strategy is in
tatters they're trying to re-hire more
than 90 officers and the safety
authorities still don't have a date as
to when they can inspect the ships to
see if they're safe
every day these ships are tied up p o
loses a million pounds and this episode
has already costed its reputation but
there's no sign yet of a change of
course
or any genuine remorse
i
um
i would make this decision again i'm
afraid paul kelso sky news in dover